[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan, and welcome
to the Break Point.
And I'm here with Loreena Lee.
LOREENA LEE: Hi, I'm
Loreena Lee.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So what
do you do at Google?
LOREENA LEE: I actually work
on Gmail, and I'm focused
primarily on performance, so
making it faster as well as
making sure we're using the
right amount of memory.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Nice,
well that's good.
Good thing you're here, because
we're here today to
talk about understanding the
way memory works inside
JavaScript and how to profile
your usage of memory inside
Chrome dev tools.
So I'm going to spend a little
bit of time talking about the
conceptual material for how
JavaScript manages memory.
And then Loreena is going to
show us a really cool demo of
using Chrome dev tools.
So JavaScript variables can
be of four primary types--
the boolean type, which just
true or false canonical
values, the number type, which
is any double precision
floating point number, the
string, which is a UTF-16
encoded character array,
or an object, which
is a key value map.
For those of you familiar
with JavaScript, this
is very basic stuff.
But we're just going to start
from scratch and build up.
So objects are built around
key value mapping.
So the key goes in the
square brackets.
And this is always a string.
No matter what you put in
it, it's going to be
coerced into a string.
And then use that as the
look up into the table.
And then for value, you can
store any JavaScript object
inside of the value.
So a key fundamental concept
of memory and JavaScript is
the object graph.
So we're looking at a whole
bunch of circles and lines on
this slide.
But let's start from the left
at the blue circle.
This is the root object inside
the memory management system.
This is not something that you
can explicitly manipulate or
do anything with, but this is
just where every object that
you create descends from.
And so this is called
the root.
And from the root, it references
global variables
and other global state that's
available to the browser.
The red objects are
object variables.
So these can reference
other variables.
And the green circles are
scalar variables, like a
boolean or a number that can't
reference anything else.
And you can see the green note
at the end there, on the upper
right part of the screen with
the yellow arrow, this is the
terminating node in this part
of the object graph.
So objects have a concept
of a retaining tree.
And this is the paths along the
graph that are keeping the
object from being classified
as memory.
So on the slide right now,
you can see a green node.
And let's look at the
retaining tree
for this green node.
So the retaining tree is
this yellow node here--
the root node--
as well as this other path from
the root to the other
yellow node as well.
So the object actually has two
paths that are keeping it
pinned into memory.
If both of these paths are
terminated, then the object
becomes garbage and eventually
is collected.
Objects have two sizes.
They have a shallow size, which
is just the size of the
actual object.
And this is usually a very
small constant value.
I think on my system, an
object is 36 bytes.
All of the variables that the
object references are
accumulated together.
The sizes of those objects are
accumulated, and this is the
retained size of an object.
This is the amount of memory
that could be freed if this
object was turned
into garbage.
LOREENA LEE: If you go back to
the previous slide, we can see
the retained side of the root
node would be basically the
whole graph except for those
two disconnected
nodes in the middle.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes,
which are garbage.
So from the root node, the
retain sizes is the size of
everything that's
still reachable.
So what exactly is garbage?
Well, the definition of garbage
is any variable and
all variables which cannot be
reached from the root node.
So in this diagram here, I've
highlighted the two nodes
which are garbage.
The red node is referencing in
the green node, but there is
no path from the blue root node
to that red node, making
both the red and the green
node into garbage.
So garbage collection happens
in two phases.
First, the graph is scanned,
and all garbage is found.
So we already know the garbage
in this graph was the red and
the green node.
And then this memory is returned
to the system during
the collection phase.
So it's important when
optimizing for performance and
memory usage to understand
the cost model
for allocating memory.
So every time that your
JavaScript application calls
new, it reserves memory from
something called the young
memory pool.
So memory is split into young
objects and old objects.
The v8 internally decides when
to promote an object from the
young memory pool to the
old memory pool.
You don't have any control over
that, but when you call
new, you're going to be scooping
up memory from the
young memory pool, which
is very cheap.
It's actually incredibly fast
until the on memory pool runs
out of memory.
And at that point, the young
memory pool is scanned, and
all of the garbage is collected,
freeing memory,
making it possible to allocate
new objects.
And this could take
milliseconds.
So for interactive applications,
you really want
to be careful about how you
allocate objects and what the
patterns are, and how long you
hold onto them, particularly
for a game.
You pretty much need to be able
to do a frame with zero
allocations, because inside
of a frame, you have 16
milliseconds to compute the
state of the world, render it,
and take input handling,
play sound.
If half of that time is taken up
by garbage collection, the
game's not going to
be very much fun.
So in summary, all variables
that you have in JavaScript
are part of the object graph.
And the only inner nodes
in an object graph
are JavaScript objects.
They're the only type of
variable that can reference
other variables.
And objects have two sizes--
the shallow size, which is
just the size of this the
object itself and then the
retained size, which is the
size of the object itself
plus all of its
descendants shallow sizes.
So all variables that cannot be
reached from the root are
classified as garbage.
And when v8 decides it's an
appropriate time, it will do a
garbage collection phase,
freeing up memory and
collecting all the garbage and
giving it back to the system.
So allocations are really cheap
until the young memory
pool runs out of memory.
At that point, a garbage
collection is forced, it's not
just done at an opportune
time.
So you have to watch out
for that in interactive
applications.
So Loreena, do you want
to give us your demo?
LOREENA LEE: Sure, so just a
little bit of basics about the
Chrome dev tools.
So we'll talk about how you
can use the dev tools to
profile what's in your heap at
any given time, and then also
to find situations where you may
be leaving around memory
allocated that you don't
need anymore.
So in general, the garbage
collector should be cleaning
up after you.
But there are certain
situations, which we'll see in
a little bit, where
things may not get
cleaned up as expected.
So a little bit of his
background on the dev tools.
We can use these now.
There are multiple tabs, and
we're going to go through this
in an example.
But first, you want to if you
have a suspicious action, so
you see that your memory is
growing, or you think that
your application is slowing
down for some reason or
another, and you think that
memory might be the situation,
you can use the Timeline tab to
perform the action and see
what's happening to memory.
So we can see if it's
growing over time.
And if so, then we can say,
OK, now we need to dig a
little bit deeper and see what's
happening in the heap.
So we can use that to capture
a heap snapshot, which will
show you all the objects that
are in the graph that John
just talked about.
It does not capture scalar
values, which were the green
nodes-- green nodes?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
LOREENA LEE: Green nodes in
the graph that we saw.
But it does show you
all the JavaScript
objects that are allocated.
There are four views
of a snapshot.
And you'll see these in
the demo as well.
There's the summary view, which
shows you everything in
the heap, and you can apply a
filter on the entire graph to
show only certain things.
And I'll talk about that
in a little bit
in the demo as well.
And then there's a comparison
view, where you can view the
differences between two
heap snapshots.
So you take one snapshot and
then take another one and see
what happens to memories.
Did more things get allocated?
Did a bunch of stuff
get collected?
What's going on there?
There's a containment view,
which is a bird's eye view of
the app's overall object
structure.
So John mentioned a little
bit about memory
versus retained memory.
And so in the containment view,
you can see more easily
what the retained memory is.
And the DOMinator's also
has a different
view of the same summary.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, so the
summary and the comparison
view are sorted and organized
around the objects
constructor, whereas the
containment view is organized
starting at the root.
So it captures the structure
of the object graph.
LOREENA LEE: OK, so we're not
going to cover the container
and DOMinator's view too
much in this demo.
But there's some really great
documentation online at
developers.google.com, where
you can see some nice demos
that show you exactly
what you can see by
these two other views.
So we talked about comparison
view and how sometimes you can
take two snapshots
to find leaks.
But we're going to talk
about a case where two
is not quite enough.
Some other good tips to know,
though, are, you should always
do these experiments in
an incognito window.
You want to make sure that
you're in a clean room
environment.
You don't have your extensions
that may be interacting with
your app in a way that you
don't understand or
you don't even know.
So something these third party
extensions do all sorts of
crazy things to memory, and
you want to make sure that
those aren't influencing
your results at all.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, just to
repeat that, any browser
extension that is loaded will be
part of the heap snapshot.
So you're not just looking
at your code.
You're also looking at any
extension that happens to be
loaded at the same time.
So an incognito windows is a
quick way to avoid loading
your extensions.
LOREENA LEE: And then you want
to get your bearings.
So on the heap profile page,
you'll see that when we show
the heap, there's a lot
of stuff in the heap.
Basically, anything in
parentheses you should just
filter out of your brain
for a little bit.
You can just ignore them.
A lot of the things are also
going to be dimmed, and those
are system allocations
that we can't really
control from your app.
So those also should
be ignored.
And then the other thing to note
is, when you click that
heap snapshot button, a full
garbage collection right
before you click it before
the heap is profiled.
So you can assume that anything
that v8 decided that
it should GC should already
be cleaned up.
So let's move on to the demo.
Let's see.
Where are we?
So we have this quick
little demo.
It really doesn't
do a whole lot.
There's one button.
And when I click it, it will
start filling up a cache.
So I have a cache of five items
that, whenever I click
it, it fills in the
cache of five.
So the size is five.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So what happens
to the entries that
are already in the cache?
LOREENA LEE: When I first
click it, there's
nothing in the cache.
So what we want to do is, in
theory, when we flush the
cache-- so by filling
it with new stuff--
in theory, all the things that
were in the cache before
should be evicted.
And in theory, we think that
they should be collected.
Let's find out what happens.
So let's go ahead and refresh
just so we know that we're
loading everything from
a clean state.
Let's go back to the timeline.
I mentioned this earlier.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, that
would be great, actually.
LOREENA LEE: So we can
go to the timeline.
Let's say that we think that
this is causing a memory leak.
So we're going to go onto
the memory here.
And we're going to click Record,
which is this gray
circle at the bottom.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It
will be red.
LOREENA LEE: And now it's red.
So we're going to go ahead and
say, let's do some work.
And we'll just do it a few
times, click it a few times.
And then there's this little
button here that looks
like a trash can.
And that will force a
garbage collection.
So let's just force it and
say, OK, maybe it now can
clean up whatever it was
that I left behind.
So hopefully, all those things
that I added to the cache that
had been flushed out, pushed
out of the cache should be
cleaned up.
And we'll go and do
some more work.
So you can see that at the top,
the memory is growing.
So you see in blue there
that there's some new
memory being allocated.
And when I click the garbage
can, it seemed to have dropped
a little bit but not quite
to the baseline.
So let's go ahead
and stop this.
And if I go and click anywhere
on the top here, I can look at
a specific part of the graph.
And I can widen this window here
to view whatever portion
of the graph I want to see.
So down below, you see this
green line that kind of looks
like a stair step.
And each time I push the button,
that is the number of
DOM nodes that are allocated.
So you can see that
it goes up.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So it looks like
we're leaking DOM nodes.
LOREENA LEE: Well, it
looks like we're
allocating DOM nodes.
We aren't necessarily
leaking them yet.
So we don't know.
The garbage collector may
not have kicked in yet.
And so they wouldn't
get collected.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
that's right.
We're not looking at the part
of the graph after you
clicked, garbage.
LOREENA LEE: Exactly.
Let's bring it out over a little
bit wider so we can see
what's going on.
And right around where the dip
is in the blue line is when I
click the garbage button.
And we don't see
it going down.
So that is the problem.
And if we widen it even more,
where I clicked a little bit
more, you can see there's more
stair steps up when I click
the button.
So we're pretty sure
we have a leak.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: This looks
pretty suspicious.
LOREENA LEE: And on the left,
there's the DOM node count.
So it'll tell you what the range
in DOM nodes allocated
for the range that you're
looking at.
So from here, we
started at 15.
And now we've got 92.
So that number never
went down.
We see that the green line
pretty much never goes down.
So now we can go back
to the profile page.
And let's refresh again, so we
can flush the cache, start
with a clean slate.
And now we're going to
take a heap snapshot.
So take a heap snapshot,
and click Start.
So it's super fast,
because this is a
pretty lightweight thing.
So this is our first snapshot.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So I see a lot
of things in parentheses right
up at the top.
LOREENA LEE: So we're going to
go ahead and ignore those.
These are compiled code, system
arrays, things that we
really can't control.
So go ahead and ignore
those for now.
And we'll just scroll
down a little bit.
And you can see that we've
got all sorts of
stuff in our heap.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So everything in
this table is sorted by the
constructor call.
So it's not the variable name
or the path that you could
follow to get to the variable.
It is the constructor.
LOREENA LEE: So at the top,
it says, class filter.
So if you wanted to search
for a certain thing--
I know that we have our caches
of objects called stuff.
So if I type in, stuff here--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Very
descriptive.
LOREENA LEE: Well, there's
nothing here, because we
haven't allocated
anything yet.
So that's expected.
So let's clear this out.
And let's do some more work--
or do some work, we haven't
done any yet.
And we're going to click and
collect another snapshot.
So if we click on this snapshot
now, you can see that
we've got a 1.3 megabyte heap,
whereas before we had a 1.2.
So now we get to those different
views we talked
about earlier.
So right at the bottom here,
it says, summary.
And right now, we're looking at
a summary view, and we're
showing all objects
in the view.
And so that's why we see this
long, long list of things.
So let's go to Comparison
View.
Let's say we want to know,
what's the difference between
snapshot two and snapshot one
when we click that button?
And so it says we're in
Comparison View, and we're
comparing with snapshot one.
And so these are the
differences.
And it's a much shorter list,
because we filtered out now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We really
culled a lot of it.
LOREENA LEE: So these are
now showing us only the
differences between
one and two.
So you see we have this,
stuff object.
And I told you that the cache
was a five item cache.
And so there are five items.
And way over here, you can
see, if we highlight the
stuff, the delta between
snapshot two and snapshot one
is plus five.
So there's five new objects of
stuff, which is exactly what
we expected.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So this column
here is the number of objects
that were created of that type,
this is the number that
were deleted, and then this is
just the sum of the two.
LOREENA LEE: Correct.
So this is expected.
We have a cache of size five.
We push the button.
We filled the cache.
So this is what we were saying
earlier is that OK, well,
there's no leak here.
We expected to see five.
There's five.
So now we need a third one.
So let's try that again.
Let's do some work
and go ahead and
collect a third snapshot.
Memory is going up.
We are at 1.4 now.
And if we diff with the second
one again, we'll see that
there are--
oops, there we go--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Another
five stuff for--
LOREENA LEE: And that's fine.
We allocated five.
But we didn't delete anything.
So, hmm.
So if we look back in the
Summary View here, we'll see
that there are now 10 objects
of type stuff.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And this matches
what we saw in the
timeline graph, where we were
never seeing anything go down.
It just kept going up on
a fixed size, seeing
the stair step in.
LOREENA LEE: So another thing
that's great to see now is
that we can go into the
Summary View again.
And we can say, show me the
objects that were allocated
before snapshot one.
And that will show you that.
And there shouldn't be any
stuff in this, because we
hadn't filled any cache.
But now you can say, show
me the objects that were
allocated between snapshots
one and two.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So we should
see five stuff.
LOREENA LEE: So we should see
five things that were
allocated between snapshots
one and two.
And those things we expect have
been flushed out of the
cache by the time that we
did the third snapshot.
And so if they're still hanging
around in the heap in
snapshot three, that's probably
our problem here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: One thing we
should notice here is that
when we're looking for the
summary of objects allocated
between snapshots one and two,
you can tack on the sentence
that are still alive
at snapshot three.
So from the moment in time that
snapshot three was taken,
these are objects that were
allocated between one and two
that are still alive.
So we should not see any
stuff here, if we
weren't leaking memory.
LOREENA LEE: Correct, exactly.
So we are leaking memory.
And we do see that there are
five objects that were
allocated between subjects one
and two that are still alive
in snapshot three.
So if we go ahead and expand
this, you can see here that
the stuff, we can click
on one of these.
And on the bottom, you'll
see the retaining path.
And it'll tell you that it's
being retained by the object
data, which is in this
HTML div element.
And this helps you figure out
where you're going to go and
fix the problem.
So you can tell exactly where
this is retained from who's
holding on to the
handle from it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So remember the
retaining path is the path
from a garbage collector
root to the variable
that's being held.
LOREENA LEE: So the other thing
to note is, here, none
of these stuffs have
a background
that is colored yellow.
And if we look at the Summary
View with everything that's in
snapshot three, we can
look at stuff.
And we should see that half of
them are yellow and half of
them are not.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So why
are they yellow?
LOREENA LEE: So the yellow
background indicates that
there's a JavaScript handle
on this object.
So there's a way to reach this
object through the JavaScript.
And if it's not colored yellow,
there's very likely
not to be a JavaScript handle,
which means you're going to
have a hard time
cleaning it up.
You've probably lost its
reference to it.
It's still on the DOM tree, but
you lost your JavaScript
reference to it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So you could
regain a reference to this by
walking the dog.
LOREENA LEE: By walking the--
right, so it's not like it was
in the previous slides where
we showed you that they were
true garbage that had zero
path to the root
from the root.
So it does have a path from the
root, but there's no way
to access it from JavaScript.
So this is why this is a
JavaScript memory leak and not
necessarily a garbage
collectible leak.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the
yellow indicates
that there is a path.
And white indicates
that there is not.
LOREENA LEE: And not
a JavaScript path.
And if it were true garbage like
we had seen in the graphs
that John presented earlier,
it would be with a red
background.
And those are things that
are in the [INAUDIBLE]
DOM tree.
They cannot be reached from
the root of the DOM node.
But they're being retained
by something.
So a lot of times
in those cases--
and there's some good examples
of this on the dev website
that have them highlighted
in red.
And those are things that are
being retained for some reason
or another.
but.
They're not reachable from
the root of the DOM tree.
And so in those cases, you
should be able to open the
retaining path.
And you should see something
highlighted in yellow, which
says you have a JavaScript
reference to this thing.
But it's not in the
DOM tree at all.
And that should help you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So these
are detached DOM nodes.
LOREENA LEE: Right.
And there's a great example of
that online as well so that we
can go through that.
So I think that's pretty
much the demo.
So we can recap it.
Let's go back to the
slides and recap.
So we presented when Comparison
View just isn't enough.
And we showed that not all
memory leaks result in
detached DOM tree nodes.
There are things like
unintentional unbounded array
growths, so you add things
to an array to
be processed later.
And you forget that you need to
clean it up at some point.
So either you process it and
you never dumped it.
So these kinds of things can
be caught with this three
snapshot technique that
I just presented.
And there's one other case.
That's lingering event handlers
retaining DOM nodes
that are otherwise detached.
And that can be seen in the
scenario that I just
explained, where you would have
something in red with a
retaining path that has some
yellow nodes in it.
And so that's when you would
want to bring out your three
snapshot technique.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So these are
some closure function that is
attached as an event list
node to DOM node that
is out of the DOM.
LOREENA LEE: Correct.
And this is just a graphical
representation of
what we just did.
But it's much better to see
that in the dev tools
themselves.
So hopefully this was helpful.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
I think so.
I learned a lot.
LOREENA LEE: Sounds good.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So I think we
have a little bit of time.
So here's a little quiz,
the tale of the
missing object key.
So if we look at the source code
on the slides here, you
see a new object
is constructed.
It's empty.
A key called, double was added
and assigned to double value.
A key called, integer was added
and assigned an integer.
Then when you look at the
object, you can see the key
double and integer are there.
And the two values are there.
So if you were to then take a
heap snapshot and look at the
heap snapshot and find the
object, o, inside the
containment view, you'll notice
that the integer key is
missing from the
heap snapshot.
That seems a little weird,
because we just confirmed that
it is inside o, and it
is in fact inside o.
But what's going on here is that
v8 has some tricks in how
it stores integers.
If the number fits into a signed
31-bit integer, then
it's actually stitched into the
object graph structure and
not actually part of the object
graph, which is kind of
interesting.
So look out for that.
There's also cases
where a property
is backed by a getter.
And so when you do a heap
snapshot, the heap snapshot
can't call the getter because
it might alter the program
state or might be incredibly
expensive to call the getters,
because there could be many
thousands of these objects
with these getters.
It avoids doing that.
So you might see when you take a
heap snapshot that some keys
are missing.
But they're still there.
LOREENA LEE: Good things
to be careful.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So thanks a lot
for joining us, Loreena.
LOREENA LEE: No problem.
Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Bye.
LOREENA LEE: Bye, everyone.